b-rabbit your I treasure who is talking
to nobody
hello I am rt8 and this is Roman Britain
debut today we have this ripoff Jenga
two piece of what piece of I have MIOSHA
Jesus really cooking on Roman no you're
making it worse well come on and we're
gonna go when we take one we're gonna
read it out to the other yeah yeah okay
okay Joe stop no you stop no the main
character I'm sorry no you stop
no he's don't you stop you stop you stop
[Music]
okay pretend I'm director Taika Waititi
and convinced me to cast you in the new
Thor well oh my I'm real I really really
love Marvel films and it would be an
honor to play at least a side character
in the film I'd be like so excited I'm
trying to do everything I'm trying to
make most of my life in this world
didn't get I'm sorry I really want to
knock this over I'm not gonna lie
be careful man did your cast me Alfie
Allen spoil games of Thrones for you I
don't want you all I know is his balls
got cut off
all you need to know that's it next
question if you could show Jojo to one
person who probably hasn't seen it who
if I could probably hit yeah
see the actions of his terrible whale
and we could mock him for terrible
things that he's done
people used to say a lot of nasty things
about me oh this guy's a lunatic oh look
at that psycho he's gonna get us all
killed
what's your best piece of advice for
aspiring child actors I think it's
important to to keep on trying and not
give up and to have to take rejection
because before I got the part I did AC
or so auditions and it's hard work it's
hard work and I think if you can't take
rejections gonna be harder for me giving
me anxiety if you go to the Oscars what
star will you ask to take a selfie with
all of them
[Music]
Leonardo pepper no no I probably choose
[Music]
I think it's like going to a slump like
the tower Pisa
no no you can't do that cheese me okay
you'll go okay I'm gonna have great hair
by the end of this which toda raba cast
member ruined the most take me I
couldn't stop laughing
I'd like a laughing disorder I couldn't
stop and he's seen with like rebel or
Steven or Tai Chi oh yeah yep okay so we
need somebody to walk the clones okay if
it's Connor your hands and wins an Oscar
what we say - or I can graduate I might
eat later for now I'm just going to chew
on these grapes taking the fungus
[Music]
recreate how you reacted when you got
the part
in Jojo rubbing
[Laughter]
other than Georgia rubber what movie
makes you laugh the hottest probably a
reboot of Ace Ventura yeah there they do
do sign me up
why was your imaginary friend growing up
mine was probably I used to pretend that
Anakin Skywalker was my brother and Yoda
was like my uncle from afar and our fate
it was like my dad I didn't have any
friends as you could tell that's not
true you got me you know I mean I'm an
alien
[Music]